we got so many positive voicemails about
my interview yesterday with michael moss
uh on uh how people become addicted to
food in a sense
um and how big food industry giants
have a role to play in that here's a
voicemail left on our voicemail number
2192 david p
of course the show is playing in the
background that's almost a requisite for
some of our favorite callers
no but we love this caller and he tells
a very interesting story take a listen
to this
excellent segment with the fella from
the new york times mike
the nutritionist listen
i have the copd i've had a
real bad rad go to the hospital i
couldn't breathe for an hour and a half
on three different occasions
yeah i stopped eating
regular you know junk
like potato chips and ice cream
but recently i've used just
baked potatoes oatmeal
fresh pineapple and
bananas right in series and water
and orange juice that's it and my
greeting has improved
dramatically david dramatically
and what he's talking about you know i
should take 20 mils of methadone a day
but he's so right on this guy
yeah listen this i heard from so many
people
and you know a lot of these industries
they they profit from complexity
you need us to tell you what items
should be on your list of things you can
eat and things you can't eat or
here's a bunch of super processed
products that are either
keto or vegan or whatever and you look
at the ingredient list and it's
protein extracts and all of these
different reformulations
of of elements of different food
products
it's that's where all the profit comes
from from making things
complicated and from recombining
ingredients
in a more profitable way and of course
different folks have different food
requirements and sensitivities and may
have lifestyle choices around food that
they want to make
but the best thing anybody can do is get
off of the food products
buy ingredients rather than food
products and obviously people's lives
get in the way and sometimes it's
difficult to do this or that or to
you know home cook meals every day but
the the point is
the simplest thing is oh you know are
sweet potatoes good or bad now i'm not
sure
just go with the most unprocessed
possible diet and that's what we
continue to learn in yesterday's
interview with michael moss if you
haven't seen it check it out
very very much well reviewed by the
david pakman show audience and i'm glad
to hear our friend whose name i
forget but i recognize him uh with with
the um
that might actually be a providence
accent i don't know that it's a boston
accent
um good guy glad you're doing better
glad the copd is
is doing better okay on the bonus show
today
twitter is backtracking after an
outcry for the gender neutral term
women with an x w o m x n i don't even
know how it's supposed to be pronounced
i want to talk about this entire uh x
thing particularly
when it comes to latinx which is
something i don't subscribe to and i
have an interesting story to tell you
guys about
when will the mask wearing safely stop
we're going to discuss
that on the bonus show and we're also
going to talk about a way
that democrats without killing the
filibuster
could gut the filibuster all right
all of those stories and more i will be
joined by producer pat
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com
to get instant access i will see you
then